[Música]
La cruel y temeraria invasión rusa de
Ucrania ha dejado muchas cosas claras
una de ellas es la enorme superioridad
de los equipos militares de los Estados
Unidos de América Washington ni siquiera
ha tenido que movilizar grandes
cantidades de equipos o sus sistemas de
armas más avanzados para poner contra
las cuerdas a uno de los ejércitos más
grandes y supuestamente poderosos de
todo el planeta por poner un ejemplo tan
solo 20 jaimers han sido capaces de
producir un dolor extremo entre las
filas rusas En otras palabras Estados
Unidos le ha entregado a Ucrania armas
más que suficientes como para poder
sostener la guerra e incluso para
aspirar a lograr la victoria final
[Música]
sin embargo las entregas realizadas no
son nada en comparación con lo que
guardan los arsenales norteamericanos
los bombarderos B1 y b2 los 180 furtivos
f22 los f-35 Los Apaches los submarinos
clase Ohio los misiles tomahawk que
permiten atacar con precisión objetivos
a 1.600 kilómetros de distancia los
portaaviones clase nimits y clase Ford
los abrams los más de 400 jaimers los
cerca de 1000 m270 la munición de
precisión en fin la lista queridos
amigos amigas es muy pero que muy larga
y no solo hablamos de cantidad y
variedad sino sobre todo de precisión y
superioridad teniendo en cuenta las
diferencias casi que podríamos decir que
comparar las armas de Estados Unidos con
las armas rusas sería algo así como
comparar una flamante Ford f-150 Raptor
con un lada niva y quizás eso explica
por qué tanto
una nueva estrategia de seguridad
nacional presentada por el gobierno de
Joe biden como en la revisión de la
estrategia de defensa nacional publicada
por el Departamento de defensa se sitúa
claramente a China y no a Rusia como el
principal y prácticamente único rival
potencial de los Estados Unidos de
América y decimos potencial porque Es
evidente que hoy por hoy Estados Unidos
sigue muy por delante pero un momento
hecha del freno porque esto no quiere
decir que esté ni mucho menos todo el
pescado vendido
[Música]
a comienzos del 2022 el departamento de
defensa publicó un informe que alertaba
sobre uno de los puntos débiles uno de
los posibles talones de Aquiles que
pueden tener las fuerzas armadas de los
Estados Unidos de América y no todo esto
no tiene nada que ver con el desarrollo
de algún caza Bombardero y una fragata o
un tipo de misil concreto sino con la
propia estructura del complejo militar
Industrial norteamericano hablamos del
sistema de producción militar más
importante avanzado y grande de todo el
mundo un sistema de producción capaz de
fabricar desde misiles balísticos
intercontinentales satélites militares
altamente avanzados o cazabombarderos de
quinta generación hasta equipos de
radios baterías o chalecos en cierta
forma este sistema representa el corazón
el pilar central del poder
norteamericano sin embargo ahora el
propio departamento de defensa lo ha
dejado muy claro en los últimos años Se
ha producido un cambio tan grande que
puede terminar convirtiéndose en una de
las grandes amenazas para la seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos atentos
[Música]
la industria de los gigantes
las fuerzas armadas de los Estados
Unidos no serían La Poderosa fuerza de
combate que hoy son si no fuera por los
miles y miles de contratistas privados
que cada día trabajan a destajo para
producir los equipos militares más
modernos y capaces del mundo es el
entramado que en 1961 el presidente
Eisenhower ya bautizó como el complejo
militar Industrial un sector quien ha
dejado de crecer y de asumir cada vez
más responsabilidades en el desempeño
militar de la mayor potencia mundial
cada vez son más importantes pero sin
embargo cada vez son menos
durante las últimas décadas y
especialmente Durante los últimos años
Se ha producido un enorme proceso de
concentración empresarial que ha
reducido la competencia y ha hecho que
el departamento de defensa sea cada vez
más dependiente de unos pocos actores
industriales Por ejemplo si hablamos de
los sistemas de armas hipersónicas
actualmente el pentágono solo cuenta con
un contratista principal
esta amigos es una situación muy
diferente la de hace unos cuantos años
por ejemplo hace 30 años el departamento
de defensa podía contar con 8
proveedores de aviones militares hoy
solo con tres Boeing logic Martin y
nordstrop croman en el caso de los
misiles el número ha pasado de 8 a 3 hoy
por hoy el 90% de los misiles
norteamericanos son fabricados por tan
solo tres empresas Boeing login Martin y
racion Y si por ejemplo hablamos de
satélites militares Pues el resultado es
básicamente el mismo el número de
proveedores principales se ha reducido
de 8 a 4 Boeing los hit Martin nord
grammann y Hughes y eso no es todo si os
fijáis bien os daréis cuenta de cómo el
nombre de los proveedores se repite una
y otra y otra vez esto es así porque
desde la década de los 90 el número de
contratistas principales en el campo de
la defensa y la industria aeroespacial
de los Estados Unidos se ha reducido de
51 a tan solo estos
que veis en pantalla logic Martin
radición general dynamics nortroproman y
boing aunque creo que en este caso como
hay tantos otros una imagen vale más que
mil palabras fijaos Cómo ha evolucionado
durante las últimas décadas el sector de
los contratistas militares por supuesto
hay muchas más empresas proveedoras Pero
estos son los cinco gigantes que se han
convertido en los grandes reyes de la
industria militar no solo de Estados
Unidos sino de todo el mundo
prácticamente No importa De qué equipo
sistema militar hablemos porque alguno
de estos cinco gigantes casi siempre
estará presente en su desarrollo Son
ellos los que más se aprovechan del
formidable presupuesto militar de
Estados Unidos para que salís una idea
juntos estos cinco grandes colosos
tienen un valor bursátil de más de 500
mil millones y facturan cada año con sus
actividades militares más de 230.000
millones de dólares
[Música]
y ojo porque este proceso de
concentración lo ha cambiado todo por
qué Pues porque entre otras
consecuencias la falta de competencia
conlleva menos innovación y mayores
costes claro a ver Es lógico si no tiene
Rivales en el mercado que te puedan
sustituir como empresa vas a tener muy
pocos incentivos para invertir más de la
cuenta en Innovación o para reducir tus
precios es un problema del que ya os
hemos hablado en visual economic nuestro
canal hermano de economía Cómo un
momento que aún no conocen visual
economic pues no esperes más en los
últimos vídeos os hemos hablado por
ejemplo de tan interesantes como la
enfermedad que impide que América Latina
abrace otra vez por todas el camino al
desarrollo o como los políticos y
también los expertos nos mienten con las
previsiones del sistema de pensiones en
España que por cierto es uno de los
grandes puntos negros de las finanzas
europeas en fin os dejo un par de
enlaces abajo en la descripción pero no
nos decimos
[Música]
El caso es que según datos del propio
gobierno de los Estados Unidos las
pequeñas empresas generan 16 veces y
media más patentes que los grandes
gigantes corporativos sin embargo
durante la última década el número de
pequeñas empresas en el complejo
Industrial militar norteamericano se ha
reducido un 40%. y que no cambiar las
cosas podrían desaparecer otros 15.000
proveedores en los próximos 10 años lo
que como veis supondría mucha menos
innovación y eso no es todo porque más
costes y menos Innovación no es la única
consecuencia que tiene que este mercado
esté siendo copado cada vez más por las
cinco grandes corporaciones que ya lo
dominan eso supone por ejemplo Que si
uno de estos cinco colosos falla en el
desarrollo de un nuevo tipo de arma el
pentágono podría encontrarse sin
alternativas al menos sin alternativas
locales y podéis creerme cuando os
decimos que lo de contar con proveedores
locales es algo que en Washington
consideran crítico para la seguridad
nacional aún más al haber menos
proveedores estos también suelen tener
menos capacidad de fabricación excelente
lo que conlleva mucha más dificultad
para incrementar repentinamente sus
niveles de producción que por qué es
esto así pues mira porque cuando una
empresa compra otra o se fusiona con un
rival lo hace fundamentalmente para
generar sinergias por ejemplo reduciendo
los excedentes de capacidad con los que
suelen trabajar las empresas pongamos un
ejemplo que así se ve todo mejor
imaginemos dos grandes empresas que
tienen cinco fábricas cada una estas
fábricas son capaces de producir digamos
2000 misiles por año es decir 200 por
fábrica sin embargo cada una de estas
empresas solo venden cada año 850
misiles esto supone que tienen un
excedente de capacidad de 300 misiles
pero si se fusionan podrían cerrar por
completo una de esas fábricas y seguir
vendiendo sus 1.700 misiles por año
incluso al haberse reducido la
competencia es posible que pudieran
vender cada uno de estos misiles a un
precio más elevado de esta forma la
nueva empresa Sería mucho más eficiente
y tendría más beneficios y sabéis que
estas son Ni más ni menos la sinergias
que justifican las compras y las
fusiones corporativas que hemos visto en
los últimos años El problema es que al
tiempo que estas empresas logran ser más
eficientes También tienen menos margen
de maniobra y llegada del caso podrían
hacer que el ejército no tuviera
suficiente disponibilidad de suministros
y equipos clave
y eso no es todo porque otra forma de
conseguir sinergias es reducir empleados
lo que supone que cada vez haya menos
trabajadores especializados en el sector
lo que a medio y largo plazo limita aún
más la capacidad de respuesta a una
necesidad de producción extraordinaria
y ojo porque como veremos Esto es algo
que cada vez está preocupando más en
Estados Unidos por ahora hay una
pregunta obligada es que acaso en
Washington no son conscientes de esta
situación porque no han hecho nada pues
lo cierto es que son perfectamente
conscientes de este problema
Durante los últimos 10 años el
departamento de defensa por ejemplo ha
incrementado un 83% de su presupuesto
para apoyarla y más de de estas pequeñas
empresas y en un 28% sus compras a estos
mismos proveedores sin embargo nada de
esto ha sido suficiente para frenar la
pérdida de compañías en el sector más
bien todo lo contrario el proceso de
concentración no solo no se ralentizó
sino que incluso se aceleró
y claro entonces Os preguntaréis por qué
demonios está produciendo esta acelerada
concentración de empresas Y por qué su
velocidad Durante los últimos años
parece vertiginosa pues queridos amigos
amigas podemos señalar tres grandes
motivos
primero la evidencia histórica dice que
en la industria militar la compra y las
fusiones de empresas se aceleran cuando
los presupuestos militares se congelan o
se reducen y a ver claro es de cajón Si
de repente la tarta es más pequeña el
incentivo para generar sinergias es
mucho mayor y esto es precisamente lo
que ha ocurrido durante los últimos años
tras la vorágine de gasto que supuso Las
Guerras de Irak y Afganistán el gasto
militar de Estados Unidos se ha reducido
en segundo lugar los bajos tipos de
interés siempre hacen que este tipo de
operaciones sean más fáciles Si
necesitas dinero para comprar a Tu rival
Cuanto más bajo sean los tipos más fácil
te resulta y en los últimos años los
tipos han estado más bajos que nunca y
tercero tanto la complejidad de los
procesos burocráticos de compra como de
la propia tecnología no ha dejado de
crecer
[Música]
por ejemplo solo el reglamento Federal
de adquisiciones tiene más de 2.000
páginas es decir que para ganar un
concurso hace falta gastarse un montón
de pasta en abogados y especialistas tan
solo para lidiar con la administración
hoy se tardan años y años en desarrollar
un nuevo equipo militar Y eso supone que
una empresa tiene que invertir muchos
recursos y esperar mucho muchísimo
tiempo hasta que llegan los retornos y
ahí las grandes corporaciones tienen
mucha ventaja
el caso queridos amigos amigas es que
las consecuencias de que cada vez haya
menos proveedores en algo bien conocido
pero ahora la Guerra de Ucrania ha hecho
saltar las alarmas un momento como la
Guerra de Ucrania qué tiene que ver en
todo esto la Guerra de Ucrania pues
atentos
[Música]
La debilidad que se ha conocido en
Ucrania
como decíamos antes Si algo ha dejado
claro la Guerra de Ucrania es la enorme
superioridad de los equipos
norteamericanos sin embargo al mismo
tiempo también ha mostrado una
importante debilidad la ayuda de
Washington a Ucrania ha reducido mucho
las existencias estadounidenses de
sistemas como los misiles tierra aire
stinger los obuses m77 la munición de
150 milímetros y los misiles antitanque
jabalí y cuál es el problema Pues que
ahora las empresas que los fabrican
dicen que tardarán años en reponer los
equipos gastados
por ejemplo el misil antiaéreo portátil
stinger ha resultado clave la defensa de
Ucrania en tanto en cuanto se ha
convertido en una pesadilla para los
aviones y los helicópteros rusos en
total Estados Unidos le ha entregado al
ejército ucraniano más de 1.400 stingers
El problema es que la falta de pedidos
hizo que las líneas de producción de los
stingers prácticamente se cerraran por
completo en el año 2005 y ahora no es
fácil volver a ponerlas en marcha
Estados Unidos de hecho todavía no ha
podido entregar un pedido que Taiwán
hizo en 2019
otro ejemplo la logic Martin ha dicho
que tardará años en duplicar su actual
producción de jabalings Por qué Pues
básicamente porque no tiene suficiente
capacidad excedente en el mercado no hay
problema de las alternativos
[Música]
precisamente por eso ahora el
departamento de defensa está diciendo
que Estados Unidos tiene que tener
líneas de producción redundantes incluso
aunque esto incremente los costes de las
empresas y también del contribuyente
Claro está Y es que una cosa es la
Guerra de Ucrania y otra muy distinta a
pensar en un conflicto mucho más
importante Por ejemplo en una posible
invasión China de Taiwán los arsenales
norteamericanos tienen los equipos más
modernos Sí pero una superpotencia tiene
que también tener la capacidad de
responder con rapidez a un incremento de
la producción y eso como veis en los
últimos años se ha reducido y mucho con
el vertiginoso proceso de concentración
que se ha dado
y luego no estaría de más evitar cometer
algunos excesos recordad si no el caso
del f-35 el proyecto nació con el
objetivo de crear un equipo asequible en
principio el programa estaba llamado
acostar unos 200.000 millones de dólares
Pues bien entre el 2001 y el 2020 lleva
ya consumidos más de 400 mil millones y
lo que queda tiene lo que ver en todo
esto la falta de competencia Pues no lo
sé pero la ciencia económica dice
claramente que sí
sea como sea este es ahora uno de los
grandes talones de Aquiles que ha sido
reconocido por el propio departamento de
defensa la concentración empresarial
puede favorecer la eficiencia y la
capacidad de desarrollar proyectos muy
grandes Sí eso no es tan duda Pero
quizás se ha ido demasiado lejos Claro
que tampoco parece que sus rivales estén
mucho mejor pero ya sabéis que en
Estados Unidos la cuestión militar se la
toman muy pero que muy en serio En
cualquier caso la pregunta ahora es para
ti qué poder crees que realmente tienen
estas grandes corporaciones militares
desde tu punto de vista Cuáles son los
mayores retos a los que Estados Unidos
se enfrenta para continuar siendo una
superpotencia déjanos tu respuesta abajo
en los comentarios y si este vídeo te
resulta interesante olvides darle al
botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho y ojo si te gusta la economía
Échale un vistazo también aviso al
economic un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]